le site de l' usine a été lui
entièrement dévastés stupéfiante image
qui rappelle celle d'un bombardement
plusieurs bâtiments proches ont été
partiellement ou totalement détruits
valérie ermite
c'était un complexe industriel
il n'en reste plus rien 10h20 ce matin
une explosion gigantesque dévastent
l'usiné pétrochimique à z
une usine qui produit des engrais à la
périphérie de toulouse
l'explosion aurait eu lieu dans l'un des
ateliers d'azf une tour de stockage de
nitrate à sa place désormais un cratère
de près de 50 mètres de diamètre on a eu
une explosion
en tout ce qu'on pouvait dans l'état où
on en est là je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus pour l'instant
donc toute première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés évacués les
employés du site
près de 350 personnes se trouvaient dans
l'usiné et des centaines d'autres dans
les bâtiments alentour souffler eux
aussi par la violence de l'explosion
juste à côté jusqu'en 2000
et je me suis reconduit j'ai vu des
femmes qui monte dans le ciel est d'un
grand souffle et voilà il y avait tout
de retourner tout un grand massacre
des blessés partout moi j'ai vu juste à
côté de l'usiné où on travaillé et
j'avais la tête ouverte
combien de morts combien de blessés sous
ces bâtiments effondrés ces voitures des
trucs
les clients des magasins darty tout
proche de l' usine serait aussi décédée
sur la rocade de toulouse qui jouxte le
site
la vie c'est comme arrêter des dizaines
de voitures sont endommagés des dizaines
de passagers sont blessés
quand vous regardez soit après avoir fui
ont comme une bombe qui a explosé là bas
voilà ma fille eton visuel a essayé de
garder la maîtrise du jeu d'une semaine
cet accident trois yards du coup comme
ça on voulait plus une explosion mais
c'est tout on entendu une grosse
explosion
l'origine de l'explosion n'est toujours
pas déterminée
le bilan est encore incertain mais
d'ores et déjà cette catastrophe est la
plus meurtrière qu'ait connu l'industrie
chimique en france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]